con i suo benvenuti in questo nuovo
video
se vi può interessare qui c'è scritto
marina in giapponese e ce lo stavamo
chiedendo tudini e oggi assaggeremo dei
cibi giapponesi che sono contenuti in
questa sacca chi di voi mi segue su
instagram avrà visto che sono stata a
tokyo ho fatto un viaggio con un brand
di make up e questo brand in camera mi
ha fatto trovare delle sorpresine vedere
sorpresine sia beauty quindi dei trucchi
che del cibo
io ovviamente li non l'ho assaggiato
perché ho detto poi torno a milano e
giro il video con i miei compari un nido
e andré siete pronti city car e come
iniziamo allora iniziamo con un kit kat
al gusto che sarà marcia sicuro raga che
chi con i ragazzi ho capito che sa di
morte allora ci sono due
facciamo la divisione equa ed o che non
provavo quattro e tu no altro pezzetto e
andré si vedeva loro non vale cioè il
bacino ragazze animato
premendo niente c'era l'esigenza di
prendere i fazzolettini perché io andrei
avanti speriamo ci sia qualcosa che
tolga questo gusto amarissima tremendo
un altro kit kat
all mi sembra abbastanza evidente che
sia al gusto castagna beh stiamo
parlando bianco secondo me facciamo
sempre le solite divisioni urbino allora
l'odore è salito per cani diciamo che
sono di castagne suggerite già espulse o
schifo schifo è un po fa cup e che non
sa mica una taglia catania non è così
tremendo bocciatissimo o ma non
prendiamoci la bocca con delle ed eccoci
sito inglese scioperi o programmi che vi
sono delle fantastiche caramelle gommose
uno yogurt al allo yogurt alla fragola
iniziamo con l'odore degustazione e farà
schifo come molto naturale devo dire che
sento proprio grappa sento proprio i
prati in fiore
a me il naso ma bruciato è siamo fatti
dai a questo patrimonio
e tutto odore perché sapore non esiste
acido ma fanno tremare attiva è stato e
limone non è lo yogurt un altro sa di
limone in discoteca
un altro anche io l'altro ragazzi ma
fate schifo vi piace alle cose chimiche
ed eva fabian da usare e perché no
proprio melandri il naso dentro il odore
tremendo sono proprio medico
buonissime wow quando sarà un po di
giudice giù di morale mi hai detto
vicino al comodino mi riprendo allora
non vedevo l'ora di questi bastoncini
ignoti ma soprattutto si chiamano pochi
perché o legno coperto di fragola vabbè
però pensavo peggio
il tablet chimica tremenda di cui
capisco tutto questo e pisa con miss
costino edoardo chiavi stia vicino alla
pausa pranzo è dello studentato siamo
affamati
diciamo che per adesso il meno peggio
siamo d'accordo
the winners con un bel latte
allora questo si chiama ozeki sarà che
assumo con un bel lottatore di sumo
davanti ovviamente non ho idea di cosa
sia sull acqua
sarà succo sarà latte sarà fatto il bene
e il male
apriamo e scopriamo che devi aprirci
ragazzi ora c'è un odore molto acre a
secco o album e noi ci sentiamo su cos'è
alcolico ecco la mail ora non ho asta di
acetone allora tutto da accertare o
legata ma siamo sicuri che sia
commestibile però non lo sai cos'è tipo
acqua all'aloe palco con una roba del
genere secondo me no perché sono ragazze
di aceto nostra di aceto dove aceto
ma non sicuri non e aceto perché noi le
cose da allora oggi faremo come i gatti
amo ma non me ne importa come scusa la
cresta no
nel bagno non in cucina sono sicuro
io faccio io prego dimmi che è
commestibile comunque padre che di
michele come andrà tutto bene una cosa
con me perché a marzo ma scusami allora
era in mezzo al cibo c'è scritto 500 ml
anch'io paure che non sia commestibile
scade il 4 2 e 19 ha detto la scadenza
sai la cosa fa tipo di vino ma andare va
male pensa vista solo di quella notte
alcolica senza vino certamente il vino
che non sarei me no dai assaggiare do a
te prego
come fanno a milano senza vino senza
aver assaggiato anche come prima come
l'amarone è l'unico e vero che
stupidamente che niente più cresce mi va
beh io non mi fido o le reazioni sono
state abbastanza forti tabellone quindi
cosa sta cosa
una caramella si chiama harajuku tokyo
candy a go go
ok unboxing allora c'è della faglia in
fondo finto ovviamente fa un po pasqua
un sacchettino di plastica quindi poco
eco friendly devo dire delle famiglie la
bagno sapete quelle che il signor già il
suo anche il sapore senza guardar
l'essenza assaggiarli perché dobbiamo
piangere ogni volta che lo usiamo le
cose come fai a scioccato sono daniele
inviterò ragazzi ma ce l'avete
proveranno a nato sano di schifo io sto
gioco alla verde e azzurra io che la
rosa ovviamente io bianco pronti sembra
uno stato che 21 c
immaginavo che sarebbe stato consistente
il sapore allora quello difendiamo è
come mangiare il gesto quello con cui
scrive lavagna praticamente sulla
lavagna e già non è una delle immagini
che la mia età di limone
niente che non mi ha un po di limone è
un po acida anche la mia casa con tutti
i gusti vuole avete che questo packaging
che dice tutto e dice niente
cosa sono le patate 2 carote e noce mari
comunque la sorella per una solita dei
pacchetti di marina in modo
giuseppe spadaccini insomma erano patate
e brava e la prima cosa che facciamo
ti sei trasformati in una ui mix vol e
fai a rubare è ovvio non ne mangio
queste cibo per gatti non è un addio ma
le mangia cioè sono al turno no no al
tonno sono il tonno al tono non ce la
faccio mi lascio a voi ma buonismo ma il
sapone è anche più tipo di quelle erano
le buonissime poi completamente un'altra
cosa
allora sapeva come non so come sia
possibile non solo nono
questi sono patatine la prigione è
eduardo
e allora neanche apriscatole che buoni
raga l'aperitivo questo e allora ditemi
se dalla foto non sembrano tipo dei
mikado al cioccolato bianco e alla
fragola sono delle patatine sembravano
dei dolci pronti ma non sanno di
patatina vuol dire che faccio più che ti
chiedo aiuto da casa secondo me no
vomito andiamo avanti
questi si cucinano allora bisognerebbe
cucinare come si fa con l'acqua calda
dalla hbo litri c'e il bollitore da al
curry sa molto di che al re quasi
vedevano diano è così mette l'acqua
bolle cosa fai
come questo dipendente e quindi
aggiungiamo abolirla si no andiamo a
vagliare l'acqua e tra poco comincia
allora abbiamo aggiunto l'acqua calda ma
questa delizia c'è odore di chinatown in
tutta la casa dai mari prendevamo
raggiunto queste bacchette questo tocco
di classe proviamo le sue reaction mi
raccomando sporca mit
buon appetito univano fucito l'appetito
sì ma non c'e sbava gli enti locali
dentro questo è il vostro pranzo grazie
magari immagine veramente scena aspetto
allora adesso faremo una pausa pranzo
credo ai andrè a te piace sicuro sicuro
guai è vero beh dai mari
no io l'assaggio columbia 1 un po scotti
ne abbiamo fatti così non po troppo
chiamavano l'infinita motopad ore dopo
finalmente siamo giunti alla fine del
video e per pulirsi la bocca abbiamo
tenuto queste fantastiche chewing gum
alla mela che sembrano dati per come
l'hai fatto no circa ma che ca o
caramelle non capisco continua è una
caramella è un po città è un po ti si
appiccica i denti come le caramelle
quelle due partito lamella raccogliendo
si vuole
diciamo che è il meno peggio di quello
che ha saggiato oggi video di più
finalmente il video è finito anica c è
di che come si diceva finalmente finito
questo video io non vedo l'ora di andare
a lavarmi i denti e stato un piacere
come al solito derby per queste
degustazioni culinarie enogastronomiche
di livello ci vediamo al prossimo video
chissà quale sarà il prossimo paese che
visiterò spero sia un paese dove si
mangia un bacione
ci vediamo al prossimo assaggia cibi
strani del mondo
[Applauso]
[Musica]